hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
the 15th of July today and you're
watching gia sneeze rumors of my
untimely death have been greatly
exaggerated hi Chris sony has a new
target market in mind for those who may
want to get their hands on a ps4 where
I've started with just gamers who never
end a ps3 now it's gamers who have a way
but never out of ps3 or 360 specific the
logic behind this one according to
playstation exec and your house is that
the ps4 is a really good around
entertainment device for a family in
addition to having great games I've
consumer data suggests that some wii
owners are already coming in now and
that's what's contributing to the really
great sales we've had house also
confirmed our expectation that more
remastered editions are on their way for
gamers who missed the ps3 generation now
I haven't been reporting a lot so far on
star citizen's funding since it can
pretty much be summed up in two it's
being funded a whole damn lot but now
the dev are making some pretty wild
promises if they hit 50 million cloud
imperium games have said that if they
manage to hit the target from which
they're currently just two million off
they'll create their own alien languages
so this is where stretch goals go to die
I guess or the opposite of that if
you're super keen for this kind of thing
the dev are going to work with linguists
to develop what they're calling
distinctive and realistic languages for
the games three biggest alien races I
suppose Wookiee garbled speech and
high-pitched Java chatter is an
uncivilized way of the past in other
news a report from business news
publication Bloomberg has suggested that
Microsoft may be planning a huge bout of
layoffs this comes just a week after the
CEOs new vision for the company was
announced if the rumors are true it's
set to be the company's biggest round of
layoffs in five years and it's
apparently occurring as a result of the
company's desire to slim down and
integrate the newly acquired nokia
handset business unit if it comes to
fruition it's expected that the
announcement will come down as early as
this week although sources indicate that
Microsoft is still working out there
and finally today Bioware has revisited
talk of their new Mass Effect game and
they want your help in shaping it should
you want to pitch in your thoughts the
company have launched a fan survey where
you can indicate which aspects and
features of a new Mass Effect game you'd
be most keen floor the options include
story exploration combat and
customization the survey also asks how
many hours you spend playing rpgs and
what your favorite elements have said
RPGs are if you'd rather actually do the
survey than hear me describe it just
head to our news story on gamespot and
follow the link on site if you just
serve see for more mass effect info you
won't have long to wait since they
promised to discuss the project at
comic-con in San Diego next week and now
for your question of the day we should
let me know what your favorite feature
of RPGs are and why those are all the
things that I want to tell you about
today be sure to join me same time and
place tomorrow for a bunch more news